and that is everything still trying to
get every adult boosted by the end of
the year i've got extended hours get you
all boosted annabelle works to protect
others here at preston vaccination
center as covid put her into an induced
coma last year
a year on and she's still suffering i
was the only one out of seven that made
it out of intensive care
so i feel very lucky and as soon as i
could get my booster i did do
and it just made such a difference
that's your booster card if you have the
nhs app on your phone that'll come up in
the next couple of days whether it will
make a difference is as yet unclear
people want to protect not just
themselves but their families they want
to protect christmas and try and put a
ring around that
it's enough of a ring for now but the
prime minister cleared changes could
come at any time we've had a long
discussion in cabinet for a couple of
hours now at a very good discussion in
which we agreed that the the situation
is extremely difficult and the the
arguments either way are very very
finely balanced because we've got cases
of vomicron surging across the country
now we've got hospitalizations uh rising
quite steeply in uh in london we agreed
that we should keep the the data from
now on under constant review keep
following it
hour by hour and
unfortunately i must say to people we we
will have to
reserve the the
possibility of taking further action to
to protect the
public leading scientists say we need
action now the really important thing is
not to say you know what we might do at
some point in the future but what's
going to happen now and in many ways
we're going through what we've gone
before through before a number of times
of waiting of dithering and then finding
we have a far bigger problem we would
have otherwise have had and have to have
far more draconian measures good morning
good morning everybody but it's so
difficult for the prime minister to act
because his mps and even his cabinet are
against him with one member quitting
this weekend
i couldn't support certain policies most
recently on the coveted restrictions and
plan b and if you're a minister you have
to support collective responsibility you
have support decisions of the government
and i couldn't so that's why i had to
leave boris johnson said that he
wouldn't hesitate to act if necessary
and then
hesitated
scientists have been saying for days
they think more restrictions are needed
but with more than 100 tory mps against
that and members of his cabinet digging
in it's not clear that he can
many think the current situation
particularly economic support for
businesses is unsustainable
and the uncertainty the inability to
plan our lives feeling a lot like the
week before christmas last year
opposition say a lack of data isn't the
reason boris johnson hasn't acted today
we've got a government that's hinting at
further restrictions but it's more
concerned and tied up with party
management at the moment than it is with
public health
could scenes like this from the guardian
taken at the height of lockdown be
banned in the near future it's not clear
they were legal at the time just one of
boris johnson's many woes sam coates sky
news westminster